[inaudible].
So let's talk about some of the specifics here.
So I wanted to go to one that I think we disagree and I thought I want you to,
I want you to make the most compelling case that you can,
uh,
this open borders stuff.
Yes.
So you're not,
you're not a,
I'm not an open borders guy.
This is a,
I'm not a crazy borders person or whatever that means.
I don't,
I don't think,
I don't think there should be no immigration.
We are a nation of immigrants.
Uh,
that's what's made this melting pot.
I think the greatest nation in the history of the world,
that's given more freedom to more people than,
than anyone ever.
Um,
but the open borders situation,
especially now in 2018,
2018 strikes me as particularly tenuous,
but take it away.
So I think one thing to keep in mind is what exactly,
uh,
an advocate of open borders is arguing for.
So I think most so open borders is maybe a bit of a misnomer.
It's more light.
Borders are porous borders or something like that where,
so the idea wouldn't be that there's perhaps no checkpoints are no restrictions
on immigration,
just very few.
So I think most open border folks would be happy saying that if you are a wanton
violent criminal,
that might exclude you from integrating if you have some particularly deadly
contagious disease and so forth.
But other than that,
uh,
sort of ordinary,
peaceful migrants should be able to come to the United States.
So as far as the,
the argument goes,
I think they're really two strands.
One is just that the,
the economic benefits of immigration are huge.
So the most optimistic estimates say that we could potentially double worlds GDP
by opening borders.
So we've done a pretty good job,
uh,
opening up trade.
We've done a much worse job opening up borders,
but in terms of the productivity gains that it would be incredible better than
anything else we could do a,
and this goes back to what I was discussing earlier with our obligations to the
global poor foreign aid doesn't have a good track record and military
intervention doesn't have a good track record.
But allowing people to move from places with low wages to higher wages is by far
the best antipoverty tool that we have.
So if we were going to get into the nitty gritty,
it's never that,
what do you actually have to do then to secure the borders,
right?
Cause that's really where there's about.
So even if,
if you make every economic argument that I'm like,
all right,
I can't wiggle my way out of that.
Right?
Like if I'm on board that you still have to do something to make sure that
you're doing those things,
making sure that murderers are coming in and all of that.
And we don't seem very good at that.
Right.
And I think maybe that's the leap that gets me to where I can't make the
secondary part that you're talking about here.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure about the policy specifics.
I mean,
something like the old Ellis island system seems pretty good.
we had a ton of immigration,
um,
back then,
but there still was some kind of a checking mechanism.
So as far so,
I doubt that that involves building a wall.
Um,
but having some kind of,
uh,
you know,
centralized location where immigrants can come and get documents and things like
that seems,
seems pretty reasonable.
Uh,
but that's probably the most I could give you on policy ideas.
Yeah.
Right.
So then when you go over these borders,
then your gut,
you would want these people to be governed by the laws of the place that they
were in,
right?
That's right.
Yeah.
So,
so I would be happy to write,
uh,
an allow ordinary,
peaceful migrants to come in,
uh,
and then apply for US citizenship.
Just,
you know,
uh,
make it pretty easy to do that.
Right.
Is this still a tough one for a guy that doesn't trust the government that much?
Cause that's what's ringing with me here.
And when I've heard this argument,
it's like,
all right,
wait,
if you don't trust the government,
well then why do you think the government would be able to vet people properly?
Especially because we now see what's going on in Europe where they've vetted
people very poorly and I've had very porous borders.
Yeah.
So this might,
yeah.
So I,
I dunno,
I think that will fear a skeptic of the government.
So presumably you're a free trade advocate.
You like to get across borders.
You wouldn't be happy with governments,
micro managing trade across borders because you're a skeptic about how well the
government works as am I.
And for the same sorts of reasons I am skeptical.
So I think if you're worried about the government working well,
that's all the more reason to get it out of the immigration regulation business.
So it might,
I think I'd probably rights,
there's a bad job of a lot of stuff,
almost everything.
Um,
and so the standard here is not going to be perfection,
but just what's the best alternative?
Heavily regulated immigration or lightly immigrated regulation.
And I think all things equal,
lightly,
lightly regulated immigration will probably be better.
And let me give you another argument too.
So this again is maybe a more libertarian,
classical liberal argument for a immigration,
but it just seems like people have a right to,
to move across borders.
So,
for example,
if,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
uh,
this table for example,
we're divided by some kind of border and I said,
well look,
I want you to come over to my side and rent my house from me or work in my
business or join my religious congregation.
And you said,
okay,
I do want to do those things.
And we both agree on this.
We,
we agree on the terms.
And then the state sort of intervenes is a third party in this.
Um,
what this philosopher Robert knows it would call a capitalist act between
consenting adults.
It seems like they would be violating our rights to associate with one another
on free terms.
And so I think there's a reason to think that a border controls violate people's
natural rights.
Is there also some inherent problem though that,
let's say most of the western societies,
the freest societies got on board this?
Well then they would end up being flooded with people where maybe the economics
don't work out.
Because if we just say,
I mean if you think about it,
like if tomorrow we were dressed like all right everybody can come and you just,
as long as you're not a murderer,
you know drug dealer,
you're good to go.
That there must be so mechanistic theory here where we're going to let in a
certain amount of people that your economics are going to work out and then
we're going to get to some odd tipping point where because freedom is pretty
good,
people are going to want in on it.
Yeah.
So I,
there are a couple of things to say.
So one is just if we,
I think that problem to some extent would be self correcting.
So if you think that a lot of the pressure to migrate is economics.
So people are moving from low wage countries to higher wage countries,
all as you have more and more people enter the high wage,
higher wage countries,
this would increase the total number of workers,
which would probably start dropping down their wages until you would probably
see less motivation to move.
I think that's one thing,
but as a,
as a concession to this worry,
what I would say is,
well,
we can do it slowly.
So for example,
if we're really worried about these are facts of dramatically increasing
immigration overnight,
what we could do is just say increase,
see the limits on immigration by,
I don't know if 10% every year or something like that and take it slowly and see
where it goes.
We wouldn't have to push the button,
open the borders overnight if we have this worry.
Yeah.
What do you think is philosophically the,
the soundest way to deal with the people that are already here?
Uh,
I,
yeah,
so I am an advocate of the view that you don't have an obligation to obey unjust
laws.
And so I think that our immigration laws are on just so I think people who came
here,
uh,
even against current immigration law,
I think they should just MSD full citizenship that,
that would be my approach to that,
Huh?
Yeah.
All right.
We're not quite there.
[inaudible] that's what it's all about.
So let me ask you this.
So your eye,
it's a,
you're not a fan of the drug war?
No.
Okay.
So suppose we have somebody who,
uh,
I don't know,
is in jail for selling marijuana or something like this.
Um,
and then suppose that,
uh,
yeah,
so they're breaking was a citizen of the United as a citizen,
but who broke say current immigration earn not immigration current drug laws.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you think that they violated some moral obligation that they had,
uh,
not to break us drug law or do you say,
well what good was it bad loss or they didn't do anything?
Well,
partly I think it would depend on the specific offense.
So,
so whether they were using drugs or selling drugs,
I would see a distinction there.
So if there's someone that,
and there are people that are in jail for using drugs right now for using pot,
I think those,
those laws are unjust and I would want to do everything I could to reverse those
laws and reversed the,
the,
uh,
prison system,
the justice system and all that.
As far as the dealers,
yeah.
You can't until,
until we fix these laws.
And figure out what actually is fair and changed some classifications on
marijuana and a bunch of other things.
It's tough.
I think it's tough.
I don't think you can free drug dealers per se,
even though you're,
again,
you don't think they did something that should be against the law.
The people that are doing the drugs.
I think you have a right to do with your body as you see fit.
But again,
but again,
if you break a law you have to like,
I would change the laws is what I'm saying.
But if you break a law then you have to suffer the consequences of that.
So does that do that all again?
Well,
the,
I'm curious,
I don't know.
Forgive me for that.
No,
no,
no.
On this.
But,
so suppose you have a drug user who's convicted of this offense and they're,
they're in jail,
but suppose they can escape from prison.
Harmlessly um,
do you think they would be doing something morally wrong by escaping from
prison?
All right,
so this is a good little,
all right.
We're doing a little [inaudible] always my students.
No,
this is great.
I mean,
this is what it's about,
right?
So,
okay,
so let's say someone was smoking weed at home.
Cops bust in there,
thrown in jail for three years,
year or two,
they're going to pull the Shawshank and get out of there.
Right?
Do I think they're morally,
the question is,
do I think they're morally right for doing it or can that be morally justified?
That's the question,
right?
So would we morally criticize them if they pull the Shawshank where they escaped
to the wall or something like that and they don't harm anyone.
They just,
they just leave because they say,
I was convicted of something that ought not be a crime.
So I don't owe any morally moral allegiance to that law.
And so I'm just going to escape.
But you hear about this story,
do you say,
I'd be rooting for that guy.
I wouldn't be rooting for that.
So that's kind of my perspective on immigration,
that I think that it's an unjust law.
And so p justice people aren't under an obligation to obey the state with
respect to the drug war.
Yeah.
I don't think people are under an obligation to obey the state with respect to
immigration.
Right.
So I guess our sort of disconnected on this is just the unjustice of immigration
laws versus drug laws.
Right?
Right.
So if you think that the law itself is not unjust,
then my argument won't have any kind of grip on you.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm not saying our immigration laws are just,
by the way,
I just think that especially now,
uh,
also just because of terrorism and people move and just when you see what's
going on with Europe and,
and cause it hasn't just been,
uh,
people trying to get over for humanitarian purposes there.
We know that there's a lot of migrants and all sorts of other people and then
assimilation problems and then welfare state problems.
Like it just seems like it's become this massive thing that most of Europe would
probably do it very differently if they could look back eight years ago.
Right.
Yeah.
So,
as far as the terrorism point goes,
I mean,
I think if somebody is a one to a terrorist or a suspected terrorist,
that's a perfectly legitimate reason not to,
not to allow them,
man,
I'm,
I'm less concerned about the assimilation concern,
the welfare state concern.
So as,
as far as the,
the assimilation where it goes,
I mean,
a lot of the evidence I've seen a suggest that the political values of
immigrants and especially second generation American immigrants,
it's almost identical to the political,
uh,
political values held by a native born Americans.
Um,
and as far as the walls,
welfare state concern goes,
um,
I would say we have lots of other freedoms that can potentially increase the
cost of the welfare state.
And we're okay with people exercising them.
So for example,
uh,
you know,
I dunno,
we allow people to choose don't own profession,
for example,
in the United States.
And so suppose you have a student who says,
here's what I want to do with my life.
I want to become a philosopher.
He said,
well,
that's,
you know,
that's a dicey career choice.
Not a lot of money in it.
Who knows,
maybe you'll end up on unemployment and this will in fact increase the cost of
the welfare state because now you have this person on unemployment because they
chose to become a philosopher with our life.
Um,
we say,
well,
uh,
we,
we let them do that.
We let them exercise that freedom to choose their occupation,
even knowing that this might increase the costs of the welfare state.
And so I think you can make an analogous argument about immigration.
If you think it's a right,
an important human freedom,
then you say,
well,
this is sort of the price of respecting rights and respecting freedom.
They sometimes can impose costs on third parties.
So if all these people come here,
then what,
what duty does the state have to make sure that they don't just get here and
can't do anything and then then more crime comes and drugs and the rest of it.
Yeah,
their responsibility for the state at that point,
I'm not sure that the responsibility of the state to immigrants is different
from their responsibility to citizens.
So I think part,
so,
uh,
I mean there's also a question of what we will do in the ideal world versus the
real world.
So we say in the ideal world of somebody like Milton Friedman,
the welfare state is much smaller and maybe you have something like the negative
income tax.
This isn't the world we live in.
We have over $1 trillion of redistributive spending every year.
I mean,
I don't.
So,
so there are two separate issues.
So one is this empirical claim about whether immigrants tend to consume more in
government services than they pay in taxes.
And it seems like the fiscal effect is pretty moderate.
So some estimates say they do in fact raise fiscal costs a little bit.
Others say no.
In fact,
actually there in that benefit,
because a lot of,
uh,
a lot of new immigrants aren't consuming a lot of government services and so
forth and they're paying sales tax and things like this.
Um,
but I think that,
again,
this is like a concession.
If you really have this worry about the welfare,
say we could say,
well maybe this is not my view,
but if,
if,
if this is what it took for me to get you over to my side,
I'll,
I'll give you this,
I'll give you this concession.
We could say something like,
you have a five year waiting period before you have access to unemployment
benefits and whatnot.
I would take that over border closure if those were the only two options on the
table.
It's tough being intellectually honest,
isn't it?
Cause you have to,
you have to concede things every now and again,
which you just don't see people doing anymore.
So it seems like doubly,
that's just,
it's just a ploy to get you and your viewers to the Lord on my side.
So yeah,
I don't care so much about the honesty.
Just get people on the open borders side.
All right,
so you've argued that inequality of income is in the real issue,
but poverty is the real issue.
Right.
Let's get into the weeds on that.
Okay,
good.
So sometimes you'll hear,
this is sometimes philosophers,
but oftentimes politicians,
they'll make statements like 2% of,
uh,
American earners have 40% of the country's wealth or something like that.
And from here we're supposed to infer that some injustice has occurred because
there's this,
this large inequality.
And I think,
uh,
I mean there might be an injustice there,
but we can't tell a strictly on the basis of the inequality.
So there's a philosopher named Robert Nozick who famously said,
what manners isn't so much the income distribution that we end up with,
but how we got there.
So if somebody has a huge amount of wealth but they got it through theft or they
got it through lobbying the government for special privileges,
this is very bad.
This is something that we shouldn't encourage.
On the other hand,
if we have somebody who has a lot of wealth because they invented the iPhone and
there are tens,
if not hundreds of millions of people who want to buy this,
that's totally fine.
So we can't just look at the pie and how it's carved up and say whether it's
just or unjust.
We have to see,
did people make their money by making other people better off by giving them
things that they wanted or did they take it through fraudulent means?
Coercive means?
And I think that the talk about inequality oftentimes confuses a quality with
poverty.
So it's what we're really concerned with equalizing income or are we concerned
about making the poor are better off.
And I think it's the latter that we really should care about.
So how do we go ahead and do that?
Well,
so opening borders I think is the first step in terms of alleviating global
inequality or,
I'm sorry,
global poverty I think is the best thing that we can do.
I think domestically there are a lot of government policies that really do harm
to the most disadvantaged groups.
So I think opening up school choice would be a great idea.
I think I knew the drug war would be a great idea.
I think ending occupational licensing would be a very good idea.
So enabling people to work in certain industries or start their own business,
uh,
with a lot less red tape is a very good idea.
And would in barber's be stabbing people with scissors?
Well,
this is what I say.
There are some states where you have to,
uh,
you don't have to get a license to shampoo people.
But I shampooed my,
I'm,
I,
I'm going to sample my hair every morning and doing this and I know it's,
and I probably shouldn't say that on this.
Yeah,
do I do,
I showed myself like,
you know,
call my hair without a license.
And so far the government hasn't come after me and I haven't,
you know,
poked my eye out.
So what's your,
what's your best argument then when,
when the people that don't buy into this and say,
well,
we need these regulations because you're going to have people that don't know
how to dye hair are gonna be scalding people's heads and you know,
uh,
Mr. Burns is going to be dumping nuclear waste into the Springfield river and
all of those things.
What's the best argument against it?
So while argument is just that,
I don't think regulation works very well,
and I don't think so.
I think the way that the public views regulation is probably my sky did.
So I don't think the regulators are bad people.
But I think if you examine the ways that regulations are formed and operate in
the real world,
it's oftentimes to protect the,
in the interest of the industries that they're regulating.
So this is what's known as regulatory capture,
where regulators aren't always looking out for the public interest or actually
looking out for the interest of people in that industry.
So financial regulation is a case of this.
You have lobbyists who might be friends with people in the financial sector.
They want to work in the financial sector later or vice versa.
And so they're often very friendly to the very people that they're regulating.
Um,
and as far as,
you know,
the,
the worry about,
you know,
scolding people and so forth.
Um,
I think that competition itself is a kind of regulation.
So in the case of,
of school choice,
it's true.
You might have very bad charter schools,
for example.
But again,
the standard here is not perfection.
The standard is what's the alternative.
So we have public schools that are terrible,
but charter schools have this advantage of enabling people to choose.
So if you go to a charter school that's failing,
you can pull your kids out and put them somewhere else.
And that's a kind of regulation in the sense that it provides incentives to the
providers to supply good service too.
It's almost like we should rely on self regulation or not regulation,
not even self regulation in a sense.
So this is something that comes up when I,
when I argue with people is they think that I have this view of private
business,
uh,
as,
as being sort of benevolent where they'll just take care of themselves.
I have a sense of the public interest.
I think maybe to some extent that's true,
but it's more the kind of Smithian insight where if you have providers who are
competing for my business,
they don't have to care about my welfare directly or the welfare of my family,
but they might just want my money.
And that itself is an incentive for them to provide good,
safe service.
So in a sense it's competition for dollars,
competition for customers that acts as the regulation.
So I think the market as a whole is self regulating herself.
Correcting.
Yeah.
So you're also a universal basic income supporter.
Now usually this is a idea that comes from economists on the left.
Uh,
I've heard some interesting sort of libertarian arguments from it,
uh,
from people.
But what is your take on,
so this goes back to the idea that it is important to take care of people who
are in poverty or who might have fallen on hard lock and uh,
it needs some help getting back on their feet.
I,
my,
my short pitch for the universal basic income would just be,
suppose you could take,
I forget what the number is,
but you know,
over $1 trillion of redistributive spending that the United States government
does,
uh,
social security,
Medicare,
medicaid,
unemployment,
all of these things.
Suppose we said,
okay,
you can remove all that and just get some kind of cash payout if you fall below
a certain level of poverty.
So this is kind of the Milton Friedman idea,
uh,
where you get sort of more and more money the further below the poverty line you
are.
So you can take the whole apparatus of the welfare state with its bureaucracy
and inefficiency and just replace that with a universal basic income.
I make that trade every day of the week.
Yeah.
Do,
do you think that that would disincentivize people to actually,
the people that are right above that marker?
I mean,
do you know where you'd put that market?
So I don't know.
I don't have the specifics of where I would put it by the,
the idea is that we,
uh,
so the way that,
Friedman structured the idea of the negative income tax is that you would still
get more total income by working and making more money.
So you would see some decrease in the cash grants that you get from the
government.
Um,
but it wouldn't be so massive as to disincentivize.
So they would be trend,
but they wouldn't be trimmed so much that you have no incentive to go to work.
Yeah.
Do you see that as just like some sort of inconsistency with the way that you
generally view government?
Cause it's,
you're obviously not a big government guy.
Right.
And yet this
is something that's really like,
I would view this as something that this is like government should have no place
in giving that much to people.
Like it's kind of shitty.
Like I'd love to figure out better ways to help people who need it the most.
Um,
but the idea of giving more,
I just don't know that there's evidence that
works.
Yeah.
So there,
so I think though that if that objection I successful,
it would also be successful about against something like private charity for
example.
So I think there always is this worry that,
um,
when you give some kind of assistance that this will have negative effects on
people's incentives to work.
I think that's,
I think that's probably true to some extent,
but that might just be a cost that we have to live with.
So I think,
again,
even if you're doing some sort of private charity,
uh,
that might lessen at the margin,
people's willingness to go to work.
But I think that trade off is worth it if it means say that,
uh,
we have people who aren't starving who aren't a very sick without help.
But I do,
I,
so again,
a concession that I will make,
cause I think by and large,
private charity will work much better than sort of state,
bureaucratic charity,
um,
or,
or transfer program
some philosophical level.
Doesn't that also make people feel better?
Like the idea that like right now the government just does things in it either
does them inefficiently or not and you don't really know where your money's
going and you kind of just are like,
you can just easily be like,
yeah,
I'm for poor people because the government's doing it right.
Where when you actually go ahead and do things and go ahead and volunteer and go
into head and give charity and all that,
that just philosophically for your own goodness and happiness and things that
we've talked about that that's probably much more rewarding.
I think so.
Uh,
right.
It's very,
it's very easy and low cost to just cast a vote for some policy or politician
that happens to align with your values.
That doesn't really,
you know,
the price of that is very low but right.
Actually say doing some research,
figuring out what causes you support,
putting money into those things.
Right.
I think that's much more gratifying.
I think you should get more and moral credit for doing that than just voting for
policies that you like to is that sort of thing.
Basic disconnect between Democrats and Republicans in this point.
Like I view it as sort of Democrats are kind of like we'll just do everything
for her.
We're going to say all the nice things and do it for you.
And Republicans are just like,
we're not we,
well they ended up doing it anyway because once they were in power,
they're always spending the money anyway.
But they seem like the evil guys cause they don't want to do it and then they do
it anyway.
But that's what it really comes down to.
It's like one set of people who are saying we're going to do all the nice things
and then doing them even when the results are in Nice and another set,
who doesn't it don't say they want to do the nice things.
Right.
They end up doing it and the results still aren't great.
Yeah.
Well so,
so I'm not sure,
although I do remember this book,
I was probably a little old by now called who really cares by Arthur Brooks.
Have you ever come across though?
So He's,
I think now he's the president of the a right.
And what he did find that there were differences in charitable giving between
Democrats and Republicans are,
I'm not sure if it was along party lines or ideological lines more broadly.
And he did find evidence that,
uh,
conservatives to give more privately than Democrats.
Uh,
there might be a variety of explanations for that.
So one explanation might just be that conservatives tend to be more skeptical of
this,
the efficacy of these large scale bureaucracies.
Like how well do they actually work.
I think there's maybe also this,
this idea that it's the role of something like the family or the church or civil
society to take care of people who are in poverty rather than the states.
And so maybe that's why you see conservatives giving more charitable dollars
than,
um,
people on the left.
Yeah.
All right.
So I want to finish up with a couple,
uh,
scientific experiments and you've,
you've written about,
oh wow.
I got a couple here.
All right.
Let's see how sharp you are and the previous work you've done.
Talk to me about the Stanford prison experiment.
Okay.
Yeah.
So,
oh man,
that's,
yeah,
that's gone back yet.
Right?
So this was,
uh,
this was like the research around here.
I don't just sit down with people and,
you know,
I think you know,
my work better than that at this point.
So that was an experiment that was conducted,
I want to say in the early seventies by a Stanford psychologist.
And he recruited,
uh,
more or less ordinary young men to serve in this experiment.
And,
uh,
some of the subjects were cast as prisoners in this fake prison.
And other,
uh,
subjects were cast as the prison guards in this experiment.
And so they were enforcing the prison rules and feeding the prisoners and,
uh,
having them go to sleep at specified times and so forth.
And to make a long story short,
what he found was that the power given to the students who are the prison guards
did have this corrupt in effect to this idea that power corrupts and absolute
power corrupts absolutely,
um,
seem to be supported by his experiments.
So very quickly,
I think in a matter of days,
what you found were the guards who were again,
were drawn from the same demographic pool is the,
as the prisoners were abusing,
the prisoners were mocking them.
Uh,
and he had to cut it short because essentially the wheels came off of this
experiment and the prisoners got so abuse.
The prison guards got so abusive.
And so this I think,
confirms this idea that,
uh,
you don't have to be a bad person to allow power to have this corrupting effect
on their behavior.
Yeah.
There must be plenty of others studies proving that.
Right.
Even through just the prison system.
I mean,
when I feel like every prison movie I've ever arrived,
or orange is the new black,
I mean the people that are in charge of the prisons usually are pretty bad
people.
Yeah.
And,
and like I said,
they could be perfectly ordinary.
And there's also the,
the Milgram experiments were,
which are kind of the,
uh,
the classic case of this where you just have people who are in essence willing
to torture,
give electric shocks to complete strangers because somebody in authority told
them to do so.
And the subjects figure out ways to rationalize why these electric shocks are
justified.
You know,
the person should have behaved differently and they wouldn't have gotten the
shocks.
And what's really frightened about this is it does show that ordinary people,
people like,
uh,
you know,
you and I could easily see our behavior corrupted given the right sort of
institutions.
Yeah.
What do you do as,
as a human knowing that,
what do you do to,
to insulate yourself?
Yeah.
Well,
so one thing I think is to be very skeptical of these sorts of institutions,
which give people lots of power over others.
I think that's one of the big picture,
um,
lessons from these sorts of experiments.
The experiments is just be wary of,
of giving people power on an individual level.
Knowing about it I think helps a little bit,
but even more than just knowing about it,
I think,
um,
practicing it.
So when you'll know that you're in a position say to do something wrong because
you feel the social pressure to do it,
uh,
on a small level,
um,
just try to resist that impulse and actually do the right thing.
So I don't think it's the sort of thing that you can condition yourself to do
overnight to resist my level into authority or resist becoming a malevolent
authority.
But you can take small steps,
but kind of it's like practicing an athletic skill or something like that.
You don't try Dung on the basketball the first time you pick it up,
but you take these small incremental steps and you'll get better and better.
Hopefully you build character traits,
um,
and then maybe resistant when the situation becomes more dire.
It's interesting because that sort of reminds me of the way that we see virtue
signaling happening on social media these days.
It's not that we're all deciding we have this power and we can shock somebody,
but it's like you find someone halfway across the world who says something you
slightly disagree with,
even though you've never heard of them before.
You start seeing the mob go with them and the next thing you know,
you ratchet up more and then someone else ratcheted up more aware to that word,
and it's all done in the name of being good,
actually,
the way you're trying to shame and destroy this person.
Yeah,
they're in there.
Right?
There's something kind of psychologically gratifying about being part of a
moralizing mob,
and I think that's an impulse that there does have to be resisted.
Right?
So it's virtue signaling.
It's not as cool.
That's your right.
Exactly.
Actual virtual would be saying something like,
well,
I,
you know,
I think everybody here is wrong about what the right thing to do is here.
That's usually a pretty lonely guy.
That's true.
All right,
one more.
Sure.
The asch conformity experiment.
Yeah.
So that's along the same line as the Stanford prison experiment and the Milgram
experiments in this,
I think this was the one of the originals.
It was in the 1950s and,
uh,
subjects were given,
a board which had lines of different lengths on them.
So like there was one that was very long when it was moderately long,
when it was short,
for example.
Uh,
and then they were given another line that they were told was the same length as
one of the lines on the other board.
And it was very obvious.
So it was like,
this was a,
like a,
a very long line over here.
And there was a very long line over here.
There are clearly the same length,
but they were surrounded by other lines of various link,
but it was just,
is very easy test until they asked subjects.
Well,
which line over here is the same length as this line over here?
And everybody knew what the correct answer was.
But the twist of the experiment was,
uh,
the experimenter would bring in confederates who would lie and give the
obviously false answers.
So they would say,
uh,
oh.
In fact,
it turns out that the short line over here is the same length as this line over
here.
And what they wanted to test was whether the genuine subject would conform to
the mistaken group judgment,
which they need to be clearly wrong,
or would they stick to their guns and say,
no,
everybody in this room is wrong.
It's clearly,
you know,
this line here and everybody else made a mistake.
And the depressing results is that many people,
uh,
would not just conform once,
but would conform over and over again to the judgment that they knew was wrong.
And even people who sometimes broke from the group would have at least a couple
of answers where they conform to the group answer.
So is that just sort of basic built in DNA that just certain people are going to
stand up for what they believe in what's right and with true and,
and just most of us aren't.
Or is that,
can you,
can you really?
Oh yeah.
That's a good pitch.
Like Steven pinker requests.
That's it.
Yeah.
Right.
Well I believe pinker would say something about a blank slate.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
so I'm not sure.
Right.
He might,
he might say it's something close to our DNA.
I'm not sure.
It's interesting when you read testimony from people in the Milgram experiments,
there were some people who just refused to deliver these shocks to people even
though there was a lot of pressure on them.
And it seems like some of them had life experiences that really discourage them
from obeying the authority.
And it wouldn't shock me,
no pun intended,
if there was something like that going on in these conformity experiments where
maybe people have seen the malevolent effects of blind conformity in this,
motivated them to do it.
Uh,
so yeah.
So I'm not sure whether it's nature or nurture.
I don't know.
That's probably above my pay grade.
All right.
As long as you mentioned pinker,
this I think will be a good way to wrap this all up.
Are you hopeful as,
as a philosopher,
are you hopeful for free thought?
I mean a,
a lot of people that care about the conversations that we're having are really
worried and I find that the people that I'm most closely associated with,
that I have these conversations with most,
I would say most of us are sort of world weary optimists.
That's how I would describe myself.
Like if I wasn't hopeful,
I don't know how the hell I could do this every day.
Right?
Like I'm hopeful that we can make things better and yet at the same time there's
no doubt we have an uphill battle and that there's so much hysteria all the time
and all of the forces that,
that we're not into seemed to be on the march all the time.
Are you hopeful?
I like that term world.
Very optimistic.
I think that probably describes me pretty well.
And part of the reason I'm optimistic is because oftentimes when I think when
you're interacting with people on a one on one level,
you're more likely to have a civil productive discussion about controversial
topics.
Then when it's like these huge,
you just gave this talk I think recently at a college and you've got [inaudible]
give me an hour of philosophical.
That's right.
Down at the University of New Hampshire.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah.
And so I think in those cities,
so talking about like virtue signaling in a mob mentality,
I think those sorts of settings are conducive to that.
I think oftentimes when you're just talking with a person over a beer,
you might have different politics than they do,
but it's kind of a,
a non threatening sort of friendly situation.
I think people's guards go down a little bit,
uh,
more in those sorts of situations.
And you can actually have a conversation about controversial topics in good
faith.
And so that I,
so I think people want that.
I think people,
uh,
want to have these kinds of discussions and arguments.
Um,
and it might be the people who are least friendly to that sort of thing.
Uh,
get the most visibility or get the most publicity.
But I think,
you know,
if you took,
took an average person off the street and he said,
hey,
let's grab a beer and talk about politics,
it wouldn't be nearly as bad as,
you know,
uh,
doing it in front of 50,000 people.
I agree.
And that's why I said the thing about the 80% before,
and I think in summation,
you believe that beer is the great philosophical equalizer.
Maybe Bourbon.
I'm not really [inaudible] beer.
There's no,
I've got this great thing over here.
So yeah.
So Bourbon is Bourbon whiskey that,
yeah.
On that note,
we should wrap this up and let's see what we can do with the Bourbon.
All right,
for more on Chris Checkout,
see fryman.com which we'll link to write down below.